made squishing sounds like a so from a
game theory perspective from an
engineering perspective it seems to make
a lot more sense unless you put a lot of
value
in lifelong sort of in the long term
mating
uh some kind of
value in the um
lifelong singular relationship like
monogamy yeah uh and maybe we do
psychologically maybe there's a big
evolutionary advantage to that and we we
do but we also know that divorce is you
know um and breakups are are also common
and occur in all cultures so yeah um
we're just not very good at this thing
well either we're not good at the main
selection
such that
uh maybe we're
we're not incorporating
all the variables well or we're just not
good at monogamy period
from an evolutionary perspective well i
think they're
that's
no that raises an interesting set of
questions so i think that
i mean one issue is is longevity so i
mean we didn't live
to be 70 80 uh years old and over 99 of
human evolutionary history and so we
didn't necessarily evolve to be
mated monogamously with one person for
decades and decades and decades
uh but i also think that
long-term pair bonding is a critical
strategy but mate switching is also a
critical strategy so if you have a mate
for example who
becomes cost cost-inflicting or becomes
uh sufficiently debilitated or who
um
suffers uh an injury such that like in
hunter-gatherer societies where the mate
can no longer hunt can no longer provide
resources for
their kids and and and the woman
this becomes this becomes a problem and
so uh and so i think that we have
adaptations to mate switch and to divest
ourselves from
some partners and trade up in the mating
market under certain conditions
so okay and those conditions will differ
from men and women